Yes,
the Avengers,
Custer by killing and scalping yellow hair,
also called yellow hand,
which he called the first scalp for Custer chains.
Cheese.
Yeah.
Big Ass show.
But here's the thing,
man that just happened.
All of this just happened.
We're talking about 1900 118 years ago.
It's almost a human lifespan.
This is this,
this convergence of human beings is so recent.
Killed these more probably like movies or in radio.
People are like,
yeah,
for sure.
Probably it looks like a movie production.
Like when you see probably shot each other a bunch.
I'm sure there were some venereal disease involved,
so yeah,
they probably all died of fucking herpes.
It didn't they?
They had guns.
They were actually shooting guns off.
They had like competitions and shoot,
shoot off to,
as I said,
three to four hour show.
Well,
that's why the West was such a popular movie for decades because it was still so
fresh in people's minds.
I mean,
you had,
you had grandparents that you know,
right.
He knew this stuff,
We think about like the 1950s western zone 100 years after the fact.
Right?
That's like us watching something about something that happened during the
depression.
Yeah.
Like once upon a time in America or something like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
That is the coolest.
But it's what's so funny about it,
it's just show business.
It's like the beginning of show business.
Yeah.
Will he figured a posters?
I mean all of it.
How much of it is really change?
You know,
you put on a big show,
you make a cool poster,
you get these people to come and buy tickets.
2.5 million tickets sold.
Wow.
You know what's really fucked up dude?
There was no comedy back then.
No.
Stand up.
Well that's what I was going to ask Mark Twain.
When was Mark Twain running around?
Cause he was kind of like the first stand up.
He would go do these shows and he read,
he writes about it like it's a standup performance.
When was he?
How's your weight around?
Well they do.
He was talking about probably the first.
Yeah,
he was talking about things that didn't work for a laugh and oh yeah.
How holbrooks touring as him.
He's always touring again.
I didn't know that was like,
well,
when did he live?
What was,
what was the,
the lifespan of Twain.
So that's an interesting case.
But you know,
in Mark Twain,
yeah.
They use the n word all the time in,
in huckleberry.
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
And they're removing that now.
They were moving it,
removing it.
Who is,
they're editing it and removing it from the book.
So publishers,
Oh,
come on.
That's,
I mean,
yeah,
you want to learn about a culture and learn about at a time,
well,
one of the characters in huckleberry Finn,
one of the main characters was nigger Jim.
This is,
knows his friend that they removed that the n word.
Really?
Yeah.
That's not accurate.
Well that's,
well,
that's sanitizing history and that's a mistake because you don't learn from
that.
Jamie pulled out,
up,
pulled up the censoring of,
um,
Tom Sawyer.
We're huckleberry Finn.
Mark Twain had to build a little writing room out in his ad on is,
uh,
one so he could smoke a cigar is out there because his wife wouldn't let him
smoke cigars.
So he built himself a little shed to say,
go sit out there and smoke.
Good for him.
I just want to see when his life span was
old twain.
Yeah.
He was funny.
He ever read Twain?
Yes.
He's very,
really like deer hunting.
Yeah.
Um,
what does it say here,
Jamie?
Place the word with the word slave.
Whoa.
Okay.
Look at this.
A new effort to sanitize.
Huckleberry Finn Comes from Alan Gribbon,
a professor of English at Auburn University at Montgomery,
Alabama who has produced a new edition of Twain's novel that replaces that word
with slave,
um,
peers in the book more than 200 times.
It was a common racial epitaphs of,
okay Duh.
You used by twain as part of his characters vernacular speech.
And as a reflection of the mid 19th century social attitudes along the
Mississippi River,
there is a,
um,
so an effort,
but that doesn't mean that it's been done.
There's a,
a ride at Disneyland.
Um,
I want to say it's either splash mountain or,
okay.
I think it is splash mountain splash mountain at Disneyland,
which was based on a really racist old cartoon that you can't get anymore called
southern tails.
I think it's called southern tail.
It's a Himalayan thing.
No,
no,
that's,
that's the Matterhorn.
Oh,
splashback brier.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
That was very rare.
Briar bear or Briar Fox.
Yeah.
Brian Fox.
Fox.
Yep.
Yeah.
The,
that whole thing is like,
it's a southern ride and we'll just all be singing ducks and uh,
we,
uh,
we went with a guide and the guy was explaining to us that this is all based on
a really racist old,
um,
thing that you can only get like bootleg copies of now.
Ah.
Oh really?
Yeah.
This is super racist.
Old Cars.
I had like the tar baby and,
right.
The tar baby thing.
Well,
what is it?
It's southern tails,
right?
Is that what it's called?
Trying to find the name.
It's,
I'm just keeps seeing Briar Fox listed a bunch of times.
The song of the south telling the song of the south.
I think that's the name of it.
Right?
I think it's called Song of the south.
I think that's it.
I think that's the name of it right now.
That I think about it.
Yeah,
but it was a panel or super racist.
I believe it.
There's fat,
a lot of bad stuff back then.
What does it is this wonder,
is this,
it could be due to abuse.
It is.
Yeah.
This is Zippity Doo Dah.
They sing this in the,
in the movie zippity Doo Dah.
Yes.
This race.
Why is this racist?
Well that's what they're asking is this racist song of the south.
Right now it's just the guy singing it.
Yeah.
I don't think this is the part.
I think the
reason why you can get this online is because it's not the racist stuff cause
this is just the guy singing mister blue bird on my shoulder
mount.
So side of the south.
The move.
See if you can find song of the south.
Yes.
There's the clip that popped up when I go.
Yeah.
81% liked it.
Look at rotten tomatoes.
7.3 on the IMD being,
so it's an IMD be not in 1946.
Wow.
Maybe it wasn't Mark Twain died in 1910 so that means that he was walking around
as an old dude doing these performances.
Uh,
you know,
late 18 hundreds.
Yeah.
And so maybe that was the kind of the beginning of a standup comedy.
Go back to that,
go back to that page you were just on and that Snopes article on it where they
do a fact check on the song of the south to see it up there.
Yeah,
it was,
I was going to,
what does it say?
Double?
I was looking to double check it before I wanted to see what it says it's true.
Was to say,
can you hold it up?
I it up.
Oh,
a song.
The South in Naacp Song.
The south unavailable on video in America because of the Naacp threats status.
True.
Wow.
Eh.
So it was out racist.
Wonder what it was.
There was so much racist shit back then.
It's dry or rabbit
or Fox.
Rare bear.
Why Breyer?
What does that mean?
A brier like stuck in a brighter light.
R Dash e we going to say it.
Yeah.
Brear rabbit.
Fox sprayer bear.
So that was the idea that they're stuck in briars the minstrel tradition of
uncle Remus stories.
The major objections to the song of the south had to do with the live action
portions.
Film been criticized both for making slavery appear pleasant and pretending
slavery didn't exist even though the film,
that's what I kinda,
you're caught in between language that potential you just said,
even though the film like Harris original collection of stories is set after the
civil war and the abolition of slavery still is folklorist Patricia rates.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
So it,
that's kind of interesting,
especially in it,
we talk about the,
when you talk about,
uh,
the,
huckleberry Finn Part,
like they're saying,
okay,
take that out.
And then,
then this one,
they're saying they had an objection to making it seem like slavery didn't
exist.
That's why you can't take it out of huckleberry Finn because you need to know
that this existed.
We need to deal with it and understand it rather than sanitize it.
Problem is defending it,
right?
Like you can't do it.
You really,
it's almost impossible to defend that the use of that word.
Like if you wanted to defend the use of that,
where you say,
well,
we want to put that word back in a book.
People like what are you racist.
Right?
But you can't,
you know that this talking rationally,
this is history.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
Rational.
Right there.
No rationality when it comes to dangerous forbidden words.
Right.
As you saw from the Kendrick Lamar concert,
right,
right.
I mean that's,
I wonder what Twain would say.
Do you think that ultimately like this is all going to sort itself out like
this,
all this political correct craziness and this kind of shared that this is just a
little rough patch of chaos that we get through on our way to establishing a new
way of communicating with people,
a new way of appreciating each other.
And then,
you know,
all this,
even the anti white racism and anti male sexism and all this stuff.
It's just a,
you know,
the wave going this way and then it'll go that way and then it'll settle in the
middle of yes.
And then we're learning from even these missteps,
like why can't we hate all men or you know,
anything like that that we learned from these missteps and the outrage that goes
to these missteps.
And we say,
Oh,
I understand why this woman feels this way.
She's probably abused by men and dealt with asshole men and asshole bosses and
see these people like Harvey Weinstein in the mainstream media that have a of
abused and violated and victimized women and that it is going to balance itself
out.
And the only way it goes is you have to have outrage and then correction and
yeah,
I mean that's the way history seems to go.
It seems like,
you know,
there's,
you would think in certain ways like,
oh,
we don't have to work that hard to abolish these evils,
but then evil pops up again and it feels like,
okay,
no,
it's still here.
We still have to deal with it.
And you just hope at the end,
we all end up like Bruno Mars.
We all look like Bruno Mars and everybody's happy because no one knows who,
what anybody is.
Yeah.
Just having a good time and we're all a little darker and not totally white,
not totally black and everybody's,
but wait a minute.
What about white people?
I like looking at white people.
I like people I like.
I like the whole,
I liked the fact that we have variety in the way people look.
Like some people look like seal and [inaudible] and some people look like,
um,
it was like a super white lady.
Um,
like a
cool kid.
Been Nicole Kidman.
A pitch is white.
Yeah.
White.
So they are almost red.
Yeah.
It is good to have a nice mix.
Fuck man.
It's fascinating.
We're still these very.